IT'S NOW TIME FOR
TONIGHT'S HASHTAG WARS.
YESTERDAY MARKED THE 30th
ANNIVERSARY OF AMERICA
GETTING INTRODUCED TO THE
ROLL UP BLAZER PASTEL
T-SHIRTED, CRIME FIGHTING
ANTICS OF CROCKETT AND TUBBS
WITH THE PREMIERE THE HIT TV
SHOW MIAMI VICE, REMEMBER?
THERE IT IS.
YEAH.
ONE COLOR, NO SOCKSIX DON'T
GIF A [BLEEP] WHO I ARREST.
YEAH, MIAMI STYLE.
WHY DON'T YOU CRADLE THAT
SAWED-OFF SHOTGUN LIKE A
TODDLER.
SO IN HONOR OF THAT
TONIGHT'S HASHTAG IS LAMER
DUOS, LAMER DUOS.
EXAMPLES MIGHT BE TANGO AND
CASH FOR GOLD.
OR TUMOR AND HOOCH.
FINE, YOU WANT TO BE THAT WAY?
GUESS WHAT, HOOCH IS DEAD.
(LAUGHTER)
>> YEAH, THAT'S WHAT YOU GET.
THIS IS SEASON TWO, I DON'T HAVE
TO TAKE YOUR (BLEEP) NO MORE.
(APPLAUSE)
>> SO I'M GONNA PUT 60 SECONDS
ON THE CLOCK STARTING NOW
AND GO. HARI.
>> MICHAEL JORDAN AND
"PIPPIN" THE MUSICAL.
>> POINTS.
DOUG.
>> THE SCLAR MOTHERS.
>> YES, POINTS. HARI.
>> BELLE AND SEBASTIAN BACH.
>> POINTS. NICE. KYLE.
>> MIRIAM WEBSTER BUT
WEBSTER THE LITTLE BLACK
KID.
>> YEAH, GOOD, POINTS.
>> HALL AND SCROTES.
>> YEAH, POINTS.
DOUG.
>>> MAYBE IT STILL WORKS.
>> THELMA AND LOUIS CK.
>> OK, GOOD. POINTS. KYLE.
>> SONY AND A CHAIR.
>> YES.